hey what is up guys um could be HD here
and this is the oneplus 2 company named
oneplus phone name the 2 1+2 1+2 so i've
been using this device for the better
part of a month about three weeks or so
as my daily driver so all the time and I
know a lot of people get worked up over
the flagship killer slogan that they use
what I'm just going to do is ignore all
the hype and just look at the device
itself so the easiest place to start is
the hardware and a lot of interesting
decisions went into the hardware
department for the oneplus 2 but they
all came together to equal a really nice
phone that feels good in the hand and
that's what's important so it has a nice
little weight to it it's a little on the
bigger side of the scale as far as
smartphones go
but it's nothing too extreme since it's
definitely not the biggest smartphone
with a 5.5 inch display the metal band
around the phone is really premium it's
a huge improvement over the oneplus one
and it's this metal band alone that
makes the phone feel like it's more
expensive and I like if they didn't try
to go super thin like some manufacturers
trying to one-up themselves I guess but
nothing wrong with being a little thick
dear every smartphone manufacturer ever
if you're using a large camera module
which you probably are feel free to fill
out the rest of the phone's body with
battery like this it will not make the
phone too heavy or too thick and
everyone will appreciate the extra
battery thank you
anyway the shape with the oneplus 2 is
just fine it's rectangular and sort of
boxy in a way but it fits in the hand
nicely and this phone is really easy to
hold the sandstone black back helps that
too now every one plus two comes by
default with this sandstone black back
and the texture is pretty unique it's a
little bit rougher than last year's
phone I'm guessing for durability but it
still feels great and then the back is
removable so you can buy another back
with a different material and drop that
on for a different look and feel
also with the removable back you get
access to the dual SIM card slot trays
no I
access to the battery or any expandable
storage but you do just get the SIM card
slots now this one also features a
pretty unique switch on the left hand
side it's the alert slider so you can
switch between sound profiles on the
phone without having to turn the screen
on so all the way down is all
notifications half way up is priority
notifications and all the way up is do
not disturb mode pretty nifty switch
although I feel like this is upside down
if I wanted to flip all the way to
silent I feel like I would switch all
the way down I don't know I wish I could
reverse the order in the settings now of
course this slider on the left means you
have both your power and volume buttons
on the right hand side of the phone this
was a little bit annoying at first
neither one of them has ridges or
anything so you kind of just have to
remember where the power button is and
you get used to it eventually they're
pretty clicky tactile buttons but it
took about a week of using the phone to
get it to feel natural and stop making
mistakes I pretty much hit the power
button on the first try every time now
although there's also totally the option
of the double tap on the screen to wake
from sleep if you want to use that now
at the top of the phone is the headphone
jack I kind of wish it was at the bottom
but oh well and then at the bottom of
the phone you have the speakers and the
USB type-c port now the speakers aren't
anything special it's not even a stereo
speaker all the audio comes from the
right Grill which is not very loud and
it's kind of easy to cover with your
finger it has these built-in audio
profiles which are nice if you really
want to tweak the EQs but honestly the
quality of the driver has to be decent
first I'll end up cupping your hand
around that to hear it anyway this is
one of those spots where they're cutting
corners and then there's a USB type-c
port alright so this is a new port for
smartphones and it was given in this
phone with the reasoning this is the
future and it totally is but that means
that here in the present it's actually a
little bit inconvenient
unless you have a 2015 MacBook or
Chromebook pixel you don't really have a
bunch of USB type-c charges lying around
and the one that comes on the box the
cable is a little bit short and you have
to buy another one for your car and and
I don't know is it really worth it
here's USB type-c in this phone broken
down here are your pros and here are
your cons is a worth it depends on how
into the future you are I kind of miss
fast charging but the battery life here
is good enough that I'm not charging in
the middle of the day so I'm down with
it the oneplus 2 also has a biometric
fingerprint sensor in that home button
and as I mentioned in the original
impressions video that I did when the
phone
first came out this home button does all
the same stuff a regular home button
does except actually press down and move
it's not tactile so it's basically like
a trackpad a glass surface that you can
tap double tap or hold down to read your
fingerprint and the fingerprint reading
is pretty good now this phone has gotten
I think for software updates since I
first started using it and from the very
beginning the fingerprint sensor was
quick and it's only gotten quicker I'm
really happy with it
it unlocks my phone with pretty great
accuracy you can store up to 5 fingers
if you want and it's an easy way to
secure my phone I find it to be just as
accurate as touch ID
all right so fun fact when oneplus first
sent me this phone early before the
launch day for that impressions video
you guys saw they didn't tell me
anything about the phone they didn't
tell me any of the specs they didn't
tell me any numbers so I actually wanted
to play a little game with myself I just
looked at the display and I wanted to
see if I could figure out if it's a
1080p display or a quad HD display just
by looking at it and I looked at it I
set my wallpaper I got my icons and
everything and I guessed based on you
know looks pretty good I'm gonna say
that's a top notch yeah that's that's a
quad HD display of course I took a
screenshot and I looked at it later and
it's 1080p so I got the idea and I you
know I held it up to a Galaxy s6 and
then of course you can tell oh that
looks way better with the AMOLED display
and quad HD on the galaxy s6 but the
point is this is a great 1080p display
one of the best in the business and
that's pretty good for 2015 so there you
have it just on the outside
this phone is kind of stacked in the
hardware department it's at 5.5 inch
1080p display its excellent has great
viewing angles
excellent brightness contrast and colors
thin bezels to keep the footprint pretty
manageable metal rails the swappable
sandstone back dual SIM card slots a 13
megapixel camera with autofocus laser
autofocus which I'll talk about in a
second at 3300 milliamp hour battery a
fingerprint reader and alert slider a
USB type-c port that's a lot of great
stuff but like I mentioned in that
perfect smartphone video the last video
we tend to now measure smartphones by
what's wrong with them instead of what's
right so the worst parts about this
hardware would be the weak speaker and
the lack of wireless charging and NFC
now on the weak speaker
not a whole lot you can do you can just
set the EQ still it sounds good enough
to your ear and it just won't be very
loud and the wireless charging also not
a huge deal for me if you can pick up a
few USB type-c cables you'll pretty much
be good to charge wherever you want no
NFC though there's really no workaround
for that and there's two types of people
on that issue number one people who use
NFC all the time people who use mobile
payments Google Wallet for that type of
person
this is a deal breaker this is not the
phone for you
if you're the other type of person like
me where you don't use NFC all that
often I mean I used it actually once in
a while to pair with my rx100 to
wirelessly transfer photos not a huge
deal it takes a little longer to do
Wi-Fi pairing now but for that it's not
really a big deal oneplus is argument is
that there are more of that second type
of person so they decided not to include
it but I mean how cheap would it have
really been I mean not including a super
cheap feature like NFC and a new
smartphone because people don't use it
is kind of like building a car and not
including reverse lights because people
usually drive forward technically true
but evade come on now the camera on the
back of the oneplus 2 I did an entire
separate video about that was when I
first got the phone a few weeks ago and
I'll link that video right below that
like button I can pair it at length to a
couple of other high-end smartphones and
give some photo and video quality
samples basically it's a pretty good
quality smartphone camera that's capable
of taking some great shots but it's a
little slow and it needs to continue to
be improved with software updates it's a
13 megapixel omni vision pure cell s
image sensor the largest pixel size of
any 13 megapixel camera and it has
optical image stabilization and laser
autofocus the laser autofocus is very
fast as you'd expect and the optical
image stabilization for photos is very
good it takes some crispy low-light
shots with a low slow shutter speed
handheld so that's awesome but it's kind
of slow to actually take the shot
getting the camera app open is pretty
quick I've been mapped to a double press
of the home button
just like a Samsung phone so I don't
need any camera shortcut on my home
screen but the time it actually takes to
click the photo and actually taking it
is too long and it's that slow every
time kind of discouraging for when
you're trying to capture faster motion
but I think we'll see this continued
software update
it's that make this phone and this
camera better it's already gotten an
update and soon apparently it's going to
get manual controls as well so this
camera can get better
and speaking of software the oneplus 2
is running its own custom rom of near
stock android oxygen OS 2.0 or actually
2.1 and i really like it it's quick it's
clean it's pretty close to stock Android
as you can see and it's customisable in
a bunch of ways that are genuinely
pretty useful you can rearrange the
icons of the toggles on your quick
settings to look exactly how you want
them and remove the ones that you don't
use you can go into the dual SIM card
tray settings and use one SIM card for
calls and the other one for data or
really whatever you want you can take
total control of how the SIM cards are
used or you can just use one you can use
on screen or off screen buttons I choose
off screen and then of course you can
choose what the hardware buttons do on a
long press or a double tap of any of the
buttons so that's how I made the
DoubleTap of the middle home button open
the camera and I also have a long press
of that home button open Google nap but
you can map a whole bunch more stuff for
shortcuts if you want and you can enable
a system-wide dark mode and change the
accent color throughout the entire OS
which can be pretty nifty there's tons
of stuff like this you can customize LED
notification colors you can customize
app permissions tweak animation speeds
etc I mean you can really dig in and get
your hands dirty and make this phone
work exactly the way you want it to the
biggest new feature they've added on the
home screens that that looks like the
furthest from stock Android is called
shelf which I guess everyone has to have
a screen to the left of the home screens
now so you can go into the settings and
enable if you want and it's basically
just a page with a list of your recent
apps frequent contacts and then some
widgets of your choice it's kind of neat
you can change the header image to
whatever you want and any widget in
there you can add of any size I'm not
sure how many people will find this
useful but this is another one of those
things that one plus can add features to
with a software update so I guess we can
be optimistic about its potential and
performance throughout all of oxygen OS
was top-notch snappy as some might say
this is of course thanks to you the
choice of your Snapdragon 810 chip super
high-end your four gigabytes of RAM and
of course a 1080p display not having to
push as many pixels as a 1440p display
so I'm a fan this usually tends to be
the case with near stock Android phones
it handles a ram
well it remembers a ton of recent apps
and multitasking and moving around
between apps and web browsing and your
typical use is perfectly fine as you'd
expect with higher end stuff like gaming
there was of course earlier concern
about the Snapdragon 810 not being bad
but overheating and this phone this
phone never got hot on me once I gamed
plenty I put a lot of hours into it even
if it is throttling to keep temperatures
down I'm not noticing any difference in
performance or functionality and that's
what really matters here battery life
was also pretty good this is combining
of course the 3300 milliamp hour battery
which filled out the space nicely and
the near stock Android experience and
the great RAM management and the 1080p
display instead of 2k all the stuff
combines to give my use an average of
about three and a half to four hours or
a little over four hours of screen on
time per day which the way I use a phone
since I know it's different for everyone
that number for me I would give B+ which
is a huge improvement from like the d+
galaxy s6 I was using earlier but also
not quite at the level of the champs
like the oneplus one and the Droid turbo
it's enough to get me through an entire
day comfortably but not much past that
also there's no power saving mode so
once you get down to like 5 3 2 % of
battery you probably just want to turn
it off so at the end of the day when
judging oneplus 2 as a complete package
it satisfies my like 5 pillars of a
great smartphone package pretty well
great performance great camera great
display great battery life and great
build quality and it kind of nails all
of those now I'm used to using like six
seven $800 smartphones as my daily
driver so when you turn around and tell
me this is a $389 smartphone for this
version that's pretty damn impressive
and I'm actually really curious to see
how the Moto X style will come in and
compare to this one at a pretty similar
price point all I can say is I've had my
sim card in this phone for the past
couple weeks like I've said and I
haven't wanted to take it out now sure
as a full time user you notice a lot of
things I don't even really see in other
reviews like the vibration motor in this
phone is really soft it's like really
weak for some reasons so if you leave
your phone in vibrate only mode I missed
a couple calls that way and some
notifications which is weird and stuff
like some apps like relay for reddit and
Phoenix didn't really work that well on
this
on until the latest version of oxygen OS
2.0.1 which fix a lot of that stuff and
even stuff like the home button not
responding a hundred percent of the time
probably two percent of the time it
takes me an extra pressed for it to
register but again a lot of this is
nitpicking and can be fixed with
continual software updates so the worst
thing about this phone is how hard it is
to buy one again but I would really
recommend it to people who are willing
to jump through a hoop or two or twelve
to buy one thanks for watching guys and
talk to you guys in the next one peace